I had an email from my agent which
seemed so random and just that you know
Quinn turned you know is interested in
you for the part of Daisy Tom or goo
please pick up the script you know it's
just like if you're interested how about
a couple exclamation points or a phone
call to you saying can you believe this
Jennifer welcome to Fandango
frontrunners it's great to see you thank
you so in a career that has spanned
almost 40 years this is your first
Academy Award nomination can you sum up
what this moment means to you it's
pretty significant I have to say like
it's it's very meaningful this was when
I was a kid there was only one award
show and it was the Academy Awards right
and also to have a role that was so
fantastic and a director that was kind
of you know just a director I've been
wanting to work with since Reservoir
Dogs in a really long time it just
reminded me of why I loved acting which
is something I had forgotten a little
bit is there someone in your life that
has always encouraged you the most the
person who has kept you going my mom I
think has been always my strongest
critic and Ally barber Turner we should
say who's a great screenwriter
thank you yeah she's amazing and she
really instilled in me my love of
research how to approach character the
seriousness of the craft and the care
and the passion for it you know my mom
always said to me it does I don't care
what you do but whatever you do you must
love it and you know put your whole self
into it you know about five or six years
ago you took a few years off from film
around the time of the birth of your son
I feel like Daisy and the hateful eight
is the first great super juicy main role
that you've had since returning did that
make it a little more nerve-wracking
taking this part on or were you excited
to dig in you know I was incredibly
excited to dig in but also it felt so
much more natural for me in a strange
way like I'm I'm introverted I'm very
quiet and I don't like to give away a
lot
I hold things pretty close to the chest
so that part of Daisy I relate to well
and I feel like yeah I got that part in
my back pocket
the rest was like finding her was ass
weird metamorphosis that I don't even
know how Quentin got it out of me but I
want to take a look at one of my
favorite moments of yours from the
hateful eight this is a great monologue
that your character Daisy has where
she's basically trying to convince these
two bounty hunters played by Walton
Goggins and samuel l.jackson why they
shouldn't kill her
let's say you shoot us all if you really
want all that domingre a gang bounty
money you still gotta get all our
corpses in the Red Rock okay I just need
to know first of all what is it like for
you to see yourself like this this is
the glamour of the movie business
everybody yeah there's a lot of blood
and some teeth missing there but I mean
when you get to say those words you
don't care right well let's hear some
more of these words then it's gonna be
so easy
cuz I doubt you can drive four horse -
no acting out there's too heavy for a
two horse team so that means you're
gonna have to lead a string of horses
into Red Rock and with that deep snow
after a blizzard you ain't gonna be able
to get away with any more and say one
body per horse so that's you leading a
string of four horses into Red Rock and
with all them horses in that snow and
you all by your lonesome you're gonna be
in that movie I can just keep watching
that over and over here's what I love
about Daisy for people who have seen the
movie she spends the first two and a
half hours of the film just getting
beaten up and she never gives up and I
think about you and you've never given
up what is it about you that has caused
you or helped you to stay in this as
long as you have and never give up I
think it's a strange business you
actually have so little control as an
actor you don't have the ability to
necessarily cast yourself and work with
great directors so I do think a lot of
it is luck actually I'm not saying I'm
not talented or anything like that but I
am saying I I know a lot of really
incredibly talented people who haven't
had the breaks or the luck that I've had
and I just feel like I'm so happy that
I've had this chance to work with so
many directors that I love and admire
and make movies that I'm proud of
are you forever indebted to Quentin
Tarantino what is the connection between
the two of you now I do I feel in debt
forever indebted because you know I
really was not working and I honestly
felt like I'd had like a great run and
that maybe is that my brother
had said to me no all it takes is one
call from Quentin Tarantino and you're
back in the game but that bad I sort of
laughed up because how often is Quentin
Tarantino gonna call anyone you know
right when did he say that your
brother-in-law like three years ago Wow
he could have a career as like a psychic
quite an incredible thing to say there
we are
Jennifer congratulations and thank you
so much for joining us oh my pleasure
thank you for having me
if you have not seen the hateful eight
you're crazy you need to see it get your
tickets on Fandango and watch it so you
can see how great Jennifer is and thanks
so much for watching Fandango
frontrunner
you